et dans l'honneur du Tour de France que
vous avez mis votre avis vous-même à ce
propos que pensez-vous du Tour de France
moi je pense que le Tour de France est
la plus belle démonstration
sur le vieillard il faut que les ordres
de 70 ans révoluent puisse participer en
double de France moi j'ai j'ai des
millions de kilomètres dans les jambes
je sais ce qu'il faut faire et je suis
contentera dans notre catégorie des
hommes qui surprendront le monde entier
j'ai commencé à l'âge de 10 ans j'en ai
85 ça fait 75 ans que je et je
vous assure que je m'emporte bien
pendant que mes camarades aller faire la
partie au billard moi j'arrive dans mon
lit et le matin à 5h je pédalier sur les
routes je remplisse mes poumons donc si
jeune et j'étais heureux au travail pour
le restant de ma journée je ne cesserai
jamais assez de préconiser au monde
entier de faire du vélo s'ils veulent
avoir une vieille c'est pourvue de toute
infirmité